so Prince Phillip is back home to
celebrate Christmas after spending four
nights in a London hospital Queen
Elizabeth's 98 year old husband walked
out of the hospital without any help
this morning Buckingham Palace says he
was treated for a pre-existing condition
they wouldn't say what that is
Philips release comes as Britain awaits
the Queen's annual Christmas Day address
in that pre-recorded message the Queen
will say that this bit this has been a
bumpy year which could refer of course
to brexit or her son Prince Andrews ties
to accuse sexual predator Jeffrey
Epstein a lot of things to choose from
the Queen will deliver her speech from
Windsor Castle surrounded by photos of
the royal family
and speaking of photos how adorable is
this right so you are looking at Prince
Harry and Megan's Christmas card and
that is seventh month old Archie
front-and-center
stealing the show I'm guessing they did
not have to use Shutterfly let me get up
in front of this picture here horrible